الى مرو الان في شمال السودان ينضم الينا
مراسل الجزيره من هناك اسامه السيد احمد
اسامه مرحبا بك اذا اجمل لنا التطورات في
مرا وفي الساعات الماضيه
محمد خلال الاربع ساعات الماضيه في الصباح
الباكر بيتنا يعني نستمع الى الطلقات
متفرقه وليست منتظمه وليست كثيفه كذلك
فيما يبدو انها ربما تكون عمليات تمشيط او
غيره ولكن لا ليست تجدد للاشتباكات التي
بدات في صبيحه الامس
وتم استخدام جميع انواع الاسلحه من خفيفه
الى متوسطه الى اسلحه ثقيله في هذه
المعركه ما بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني في محيط مطار مروي الدولي
والقاعده العسكريه لمطار مروي الدولي اذا
هذه المواجهات حينما بدات بدات بشكل كثيف
واطلاق نار بشكل كثيف يعني تبادل لاطلاق
النار تركزت هذه المواجهات بطبيعه الحال
في منذ بدايتها في الجزء الجنوبي الشرقي
من مطار مروي
ثم بعد ذلك انتقلت الى يعني مكان اخر ربما
هو يعني هي تركزت هذا تركز هذا القتال في
الجزء الشمالي الغربي من مطار مروي الدولي
اذن مسار هذه المعركه يعني ما بين انخفاض
وارتفاع وتشتد او ار هذه المعركه وينخفض
في ساعات اخرى يعني
ما نسمعه الان في هذه اللحظات وخلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه استمرار لاطلاق
طلقات وغالبا هي في الغالب هي اسلحه ذا
الطبيعه خفيفه وفي بعض الاحيان نستمع الى
الطلقات من اسلحه ثقيله ولكن ليست مستمره
كما ذكرت لك
مصادر من الجيش السوداني تتحدث عن تعزيزات
عسكريه تصل لمواجهه مع هذا الموقف او
مسانده القوات
المسلحه السودانيه التي تقوم
بمهمتها لما تقول يعني الانتهاء من مهمتها
خاصه بعد ان
صنفت القوات الدعم السريع مجموعات
غير قانونيه بل ومتمرده ولذلك بدا هناك
بعد اخر لطبيعه هذه المعركه بعد ان يعني
يقوم الجيش السوداني
بالمحاوله
الانتهاء من هذه ما سماها القوات المتمرده
وفي ذات الوقت المصادر من قوات الدعم
السريع هنا تتحدث عن تعزيزات يتوقع وصولها
الى منطقه مروي لتنضم الى بقيه
يعني المجموعات التي ترتكز داخل مطار مروي
الدولي في الساعات الاولى من المواجهات
قبل نحو 24 ساعه كانت تتحدث تحدثت
الدعم السريع عبر بيان لها بانها
سيطرت على مطار مروي الدولي واعقب ذلك ببث
صور لمجموعه من العسكريين المحتجزين داخل
هذه داخل مطار مروي الدولي
وبمعيتهم
عسكريون مصريون بينهم ضباط ايضا ولكن
لاحقا وليس ببعيد بعد ساعات فقط صدر بيان
من الجيش السوداني يؤكد فيه سيطرته على
على مطار مروي الدولي وكذلك قال انه يحيط
بمطار مروي الدولي من كل الاتجاهات ولا
يعني
ويمنع اي عناصر من القوات الدعم السريع من
الخروج من هذه المناطق الطبيعه العسكريه
ربما الطبيعه طبيعه المواجهه كما ذكرت لك
ما بين يعني
منخفضه
المواجهه ومرتفعه في اشدها منذ الامس
ستستمر ربما هذه المواجهات ولا يمكن ان
نقول ان هذه المعركه قد انتهت بشكل كامل
ربما تستمر في الساعات القليله القادمه
بالنسبه للواقع الذي يعيشه السكان هنا
طبعا هناك مخاوف من الاستمرار هذه المعارك
واعلن الجيش السريع سيطرته على المطار كيف
اختلفت الظروف بعد يوم كامل بالنسبه وكيف
انعكست طبعا هذه الاحداث على حياه الناس
على المرافق العامه وعلى الشبكات بالنسبه
لمراوه
طبعا محمد مروي ما عادت تعيش يعني لحظاتها
الهانئه والوادعه مروي معروف انها مدينه
يعني لا يعكرها صفوه الطلقات ولا
المواجهات المسلحه عبر وجودها وعبر
تاريخها ولكن هذا وضع استثنائي تماما
بالنسبه لها انها تواجه امتحان عسير خاصه
وان السكان لا يريدون مواجهه مثل هذا
الواقع وبالتالي ربما هناك تاثيرات
انسانيه عميقه على السكان هنا كلما استمرت
ساعات المواجهات واستمرت الاشتباكات ما
بين قوات الدعم السريعه والجيش السوداني
هنا في هذه في هذه المنطقه منذ الامس
اجزاء واسعه من مدينه مروي مقطوعه عنها
الكهرباء لان احدى محطات الكهرباء تاثرت
بشكل كبير من المواجهات المسلحه التي حدثت
منذ بداياتها الف الساعات الاولى يبدو ان
هناك الاصابه بليغه تعرضت لها احدى
المحطات محطات توليد الكهرباء لذلك اجزاء
واسعه من مدينه مروي منقطعه عنها الكهرباء
حتى منذ ليل منذ صبيحه امس حتى هذه اللحظه
ولم تعود الكهرباء من جديد الاسواق مغلقه
تماما والمحال التجاريه في مدينه مروى
لاحظنا تجوال لاعداد من السيارات المدججه
التابعه للجيش السوداني في ارجاء مدينه
مروي وتركزها ايضا في بعض في بعض الاماكن
الاستراتيجيه هنا في مدينه مروي
الطلاب هو الطلاب المدارس طبعا في اجازه
هذه فيها هذا اليوم المدارس مغلقه
الخدمات المؤسسات الخدميه الحكوميه بطبيعه
الحال ايضا مغلقه تجوال
التجوال المواطنين والسكان في الشوارع
بحذر شديد طبعا واغلبهم يحتم بمنازلهم ومن
يسكنون ويقتلون في موازاه في محاذاه مطار
مروي الدوله وفي محيطه عليهما الخطر عليهم
مواجهه الخطر الاكبر اذا ما استمرت هذه
الاشتباكات بطبيعه الحال بعض هؤلاء السكان
يعني قاموا باجلاء اسرهم الى اماكن اكثر
امنا واغلب هؤلاء الاسر يعني تركت منازلها
خاصه تلك المنازل التي تقع في محيط مطار
مروي الدوله التي الذي تتركز فيه
الاشتباكات العنيفه منذ امس وذكرنا قبل
قليل بان هذه المواجهات حد يعني خفت حدتها
كثيرا ولم نعد نستمع الى استمرار لهذه
الطلقات بما يشير الى استمرار هذه
المواجهات
واستئناف هذه الاشتباكات من جديد طبعا
المدينه مروي لها اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره
اضافه الى ان انها فيها مطار دولي ايضا
هناك قاعده عسكريه لتتبع للجيش السوداني
اضافه الى مقر الفرقه التاسعه عشره
التابعه للجيش السوداني اضافه الى سد مروي
الذي يولد الطاقه الكهربائيه لنصف سكان
البلاد وبالتالي لها لهذه المدينه اهميه
استراتيجيه كبيره تدور فيها هذه المعارك
ولا احد يدري كيف ستنتهي هذا المعارك والى
ماذا ستفضي هذه المعارك ربما هذه النتائج
ستظهر لاحقا سنبقى معك في المتابعه اسامه
شكرا جزيلا لك حتى اللح